this video here is sent over to me and
let me just zoom it in a little bit
um
and the title says richard cooper isn't
talking about this and it's got a
thumbnail with my image on it
okay so i mean like right away i'm like
okay
what do we got here you know whenever
somebody does that they're they're
they're basically clout chasing right
like i saw this a lot in the in the
manual swamp is you'd put out some good
videos you have a following you know so
all of a sudden you now become a target
of of people that want to chase up
against your clout by using your image
and your brand and it's and it's fair
game right like you know
i don't really care it it's it's not
something that
i put as much thought into as other
people it's like cool you know whatever
but
this is the first one that i've seen
with a guy talking about a
cryptocurrency and a um
a project which i'm not a big fan of so
let's just play this and see what he's
got here for hey guys i'm dedicating
this video to richard cooper's followers
i want to show you guys an opportunity
of a lifetime this is an investment
opportunity that will make you
life-changing games so
right off he he's kicking off this video
is for richard cooper's followers and i
have an investment opportunity that's
going to change you for a lifetime
really
the problem with youtube is there's it's
it's completely permissionless you know
for the most part is anybody can just
upload a video on on something and deem
to be an expert
um
generally speaking if i watch anything
that's advice based like if i want to
learn about money i'm paying attention
to guys like ray dalio you know
that's just me though
so
let's play this through
not financial advice wink wink but
basically 100 extra money
a thousand extra money and i'll i'll
show you right now i'll talk about it
but before we talk about that
opportunity uh i want to talk about
who's richard cooper and uh what he did
for me so richard cooper is a red pill
guy he was a beta club divorced got
divorced raped and then found the right
pill
the red pill [ __ ] got the programming
for the redo and became a [ __ ] giga
chad [ __ ] giga chat you know he has
the he has the money what do you say he
called me a beta pleb hardcover he has
the fitness part covered he has a
mindset uh part covered so he's a
superior man that's my three pillars
he had uh he had the fastest he had one
of the fastest growing uh
businesses in canada for like multiple
years he was making big bucks like in
the millions like tens and millions like
tens of millions i think
i'm not sure like the correct number but
he was he make big bank with his
business
so apparently i made big bank with my
debt relief business and made tens of
millions or 60 millions
um this guy knows everything about me
but then he retired gave that business
to his brother he now just you know
lives life he he now helps other men get
red pill he programs that's not what
happened okay but he drives a [ __ ]
mclaren he's a g like he's the one who
created me so basically he's the one who
programming uh before i knew he's my
basically my second uh father figure
he's my internet figure okay if it
wasn't for me i wouldn't be where i'm at
right now like if it wasn't appreciated
i would be some [ __ ] 17 year old beta
club lost in life and not knowing what
to do but because of him okay so
he's
you know he's fluffing me up right
because he's because he's now going to
use my name and brand to show his [ __ ]
to
other people
this kit is not fully unplugged and i'm
gonna talk a little bit more about you
know the the um you know the avatar in a
bit but let's just get through all this
his programming that he rebuilt me and
that opened up so many doors to me uh
i became a superior man like i have all
the superior programming and now i'm
doing the work
so he thinks he's a superior man
putting his entire nest egg into a shill
coin a [ __ ] coin basically
yeah
let's keep going he's gonna be bragging
about this lady in a couple of years
back when i look back at this video and
we're gonna look back together and he's
gonna be bragging about me that he was
the man who made me who basically
started nikita i would never take
ownership for a guy like you buddy
look are you [ __ ] programming i was
the reason that he is where he's at and
the man he is so thank you richard
cooper you're programming for success
and i'm gonna give you glory so yeah
let's do this
before we get started uh buy richard
cooper's book if you're not red bull yes
you should buy the book you sound gay or
red pill but whatever bro like get ready
[ __ ] but unplug alpha go buy on
kendall
nine
bucks i bought this one it came out
december 12 20 20 20 20 20.
you must read read this book and have to
start watching richard's channel to get
more programmed
we can talk to me on my discord so let's
begin so
people people laugh when i stream uh
like a you like a youtube video for
commentary and like feedback because
they're always like rich you're loaded
why don't you buy a better internet plan
i literally have the fastest plan they
offer my area it's it's [ __ ] fast
okay it's just
this is how it works on stream here so
just roll with it
what are the investment opportunities
i'm talking about i'm talking about
politics and pulse shane no i don't know
what level
well you are guys i know if you guys
have seen like boiler room but this guy
reminds me of um
that uh character that giovanni played
i got an investment opportunity of a
lifetime except for he's doing it on
youtube and he's trying to sell it to my
audience
oh 17.
but
i don't want to make this video too long
but basically pulse chain is like
ethereum and pulse x is like uni swap
and what are what is pulse what is
ethereum what is pulse what does unity
swap
the theorem is the second biggest
problem it's the most
actually the one useful bitcoin is
useless it's a score of value and [ __ ]
though but ethereum is the basically
first
the first thing a cult will do is
they'll try to disqualify
its competition
and bitcoin is the only one that's
widely accepted um it's the number one
coin for a reason institutions are
already um putting them into etfs funds
pension funds wherever they can legally
around the world you know there's some
provinces estates and countries that are
a little further behind but
for
for the statement to be made that it's a
[ __ ] coin and it has no value
big red flag right there right like
that's like saying
uh cristiano ronaldo is a shitty
football player like he's got
he's got no reason to be there you know
he's a he's a shitty player he's a [ __ ]
coin
the best watch in the world well the
most used one soon paul shane will be
that
so ethereum ethereum is a blockchain
yeah yeah you guys know you've probably
heard of ethereum even
but uni swap you swap and and paul chain
is a fork ethereum that means that
richard hart copied the
ethereum code
and made paul shane but it's better
there's better uh tokenomics and the
reasons behind it why it's going to do
so good and why i'm recommending it uni
swap is a decentralized exchange the
token actually doesn't do anything it's
a duct tape token remember this is a 17
year old that's that's offering you
investment advice it doesn't do anything
like it doesn't like uni swap token and
use the units are completely different
like they don't really do anything but
basically they don't work together
basically uniform is a decentralized
change just think of this as coinbase on
a blockchain for ethereum so that's what
so pulsing is like ethereum it's a copy
of ethereum and politics is a copy of
the uniform so
we got that out of the way now before i
get more into into detail uh i think
richard cooper thinks richard hart the
founder of hex polishing and pulse x uh
i heard some uh i heard in a live stream
i was watching that he doesn't like
richard hart or hex i think he thinks
hex is a scam or something like a ponzi
scheme but he's wrong like he is wrong
so i've never called it a ponzi scheme i
just said i don't trust the guy
and
i i got to that point by getting scammed
by a lot of people throughout my life i
know how to spot a scammer the first
thing that i'll notice is they're
they're not physically fit because only
physically fit people will put in the
work this dude's fat
right
also the way he presents himself which
i'll show in a little bit once we get
through this guy's video but he's he's
somebody that just like you know set off
alarm bells and red flags i'm like nope
not interested in that project no thank
you
right
wrong
i know more about than he does like i
did more [ __ ] research like i'm into
this [ __ ]
he's the thing with uh andrew tate and
like uh richard cooper like basically
successful guys who already have a lot
of money and they don't really need to
think about money is they don't pay
attention to opportunities they're not
as laser focused as i am and they don't
know as much as i do because i'm broke
right now only at 4.5 k but i invest
into this by changing opportunity 12.5
k2 my name my life so so he's put 12
500 into this investment opportunity his
entire life savings so he's telling you
to trust him because he's putting 100 of
his net worth
into a [ __ ] coin
so i mean why wouldn't you trust him
he's putting his money where his mouth
is right and then he goes on to say
something along the lines of rich cooper
and andrew tate don't understand
opportunities like this because i'm
broke and only i can spot them
you think that guys with money got to
having money and increasing their wealth
by being idiots
making wealth takes time
right and not all opportunities are
you know
fast but the way that they're portraying
this one it's it's ridiculously fast
like they're making claims of five or
ten thousand x over the course of um
point five years i think was one of the
ads i'll show you uh i'll show you what
that looks like so
this kid who's got twelve thousand five
hundred dollars into this
let's just go um oops
let's just go 5000 x let's just go
conservative
right so that's uh three four that's 62
million dollars
okay 62.5 million dollars
so
do you really think that you're gonna
invest twelve thousand five hundred
dollars and in two and a half years come
back
with 62 62 million five hundred thousand
dollars
i was listening to an audiobook this
weekend on personal finance and
warren buffett um you're not gonna
believe this i think he's worth eight
was it 80 billion let me just double
check right now
let's just find out what warren buffett
is worth shall we what is warren
buff
buffett buying is the first question
that they're looking for you always got
to laugh at the recommendations so he's
worth
111.8 billion dollars as of
uh too
and i think when he was in his 40s um if
i'm not mistaken 40 like mid 40s
that um
book it's called um
your next five moves patrick beck david
um it's a good book i definitely
recommend it i i've been talking to his
crew about doing a collab so
that'll happen soon i'm sure
but um he was worth about 40 million
dollars
and i don't know how old is he now 85 or
something like that but he turned 40
million dollars into 111 billion dollars
over that period of time that's about 45
to 55 years i'm not sure of his exact
age but somewhere between 45 and 55
years
so
this the 17 year old's telling you
telling my audience to buy this [ __ ]
coin which is going to turn 12 500 into
62 500 and that's only the 5000
estimation the other estimation that i
saw was 10 000 x which would bring you
up to
12.
sorry 112
million that's a [ __ ] ton of money
so
get excited right like that's the whole
pitch like get excited about this i say
some 17 almost 18. but they don't have a
keynote they don't have laser [ __ ]
vision laser yes i don't have a keen eye
that's how i got this far
focus and seeing spotting opportunity
basically one thing is richard cooper is
wrong about hex pulsing and plus x and
any argument he has i can destroy it
like
i'm right he's wrong
hex and polishing plus six is good i
just want to make that clear maybe he
watches this this oh i just can't
remember how hard he goes yeah no he's
not but basically let's begin so why is
paul chain and paul is going to do so
well this is the new investment
opportunity this is what we gotta focus
on even even if texas a thing right now
you can box right now which that's part
of the plan right now so uh before we
get started with you'll notice um there
on that other slide it uh indicated a
apy i think of 38 average i've seen
other ads uh posted and i'll show it to
you on another page in a bit where they
promised forty percent apy
richard hart is the founder as you
probably already said but richard hart
is the founder of hex paul shane paul
sex go give him watch on uh youtube
that's not his real name by the way it's
something like schuler
uh apparently he grew up in florida as a
jehovah's witness if i understood that
correctly
here's the twitter too but basically
so politics and paul shane are new coins
they haven't came out yet and uh it's
rumored that paul is coming out in the
end of may somewhere in may which is
this may so in the next two weeks
now paul shane uh and politics are new
cryptos and they have a lot of people
back in it there's a lot of people
waiting for polishing like uh was
supposed to come out nine months ago
eight months ago so he's saying a lot of
people back it but the fact of the
matter is that richard hart owns 88
of all hex tokens
sorry i should clarify um
that's that's what the uh article that
summarized the entire position of heart
concluded um
they don't admit who owns these um
wallet addresses i've seen interviews
where he's like well i may own them or i
may not own them but i'll break it down
for you but there's there's somebody
that owns 88 of the hex tokens and you
know you can guess who that probably is
right
the sacrifice phase it's basically the
sacrifice phase is basically a way for
you to
get in early basically at a vc level
like initial coin offering initial
public offering but basically retail it
was open to everyone i got into pulse x
i missed paul shane but you can do this
anymore do not go here do that on your
mind here it is over don't don't
sacrifice any of your money but i just
want to give that away so how many
people sacrifice and basically got in
publishing paul's sex well 78 thousand
people wallets 70 000 got into paul
shane 141 000 people 141 thousand people
got into polish at pulse x so when i'm
saying this i'm basically stating i'm
basically talking about why uh politics
apology is gonna do so well and uh why
it's gonna be a success so i just told
you about the polishing has seventy
eight thousand people sacrifice for it
so that's 78 000 wallets those laws can
be different from people like
but there's more there's polls basically
seven eight thousand people sacrificing
got into ball chain
one hundred forty one thousand people
got into politics so we have a big big
community waiting for paul chain
politics so we have users and there's
other things it gets better so basically
we have a community ball chain and
politics paul changes now via empty
blockchain okay we got that out of the
way so out of all of those people
there's one person that owns 88 of the
tokens who do you think is going to make
all the bank off this
second thing so this is the test that
right now uh policies and politics so
pulsex the tokenomics of it they're both
deflationary so all the coins that come
out day one are going to be it's gonna
be depletion no more new coins are going
to ever come out of existence you will
never able to get one
you're never gonna be able to get uh
there will never be another pulse chain
token there will never be another
politics token they're deflationary
ethereum is inflationary they have
blocks that pay rewards
in ethereum block rewards bitcoin is
inflationary two they're not deflation
they're not a deflationary asset they're
inflationary every time a block gets
mined in ethereum bitcoin new ethereum
and new bitcoin comes out for pulse
chain it's a proof of stake system
and how validators get paid is there's
transaction fees so basically whenever
you do a transaction on the blockchain
you pay a gas with a native token and
then that gas goes through the
validators and they get rewarded so
there's no there's no inflation there's
there's never gonna be another pull
chain token there's never gonna be
another policy open never so that's the
first token optics that makes a pump the
second thing is uh on politics there's a
bind burn so uh whenever it generates
fees the politics buying bird
it
basically buys up the price of pulses
there's a lot that goes into politics
and buys the positives and burns pulsex
so basically paul shane's um what's
called supply keeps going down and
that's the that's the only thing about
it the fundamental there's other things
there's advanced things
so so he goes on to explain all the
reasons why
but the fact still remains 88
of the tokens in existence because he's
saying that they don't make any more so
88 of the available inventory is
basically owned by one person
that doesn't sound very decentralized to
me
it makes it more problematic than purple
metal too but paul says the blind burn
that buys the price of pulsex and burns
it so it removes price so price pumps up
and it's it's removed so it's going to
do crazy numbers that's one of the token
alex
and it's it's it's that's the token
economics so and uh so why is polishing
policies going to be widely adopted why
is it going to be so successful like
even on top of this well because we have
the world's largest air drop called well
it's worth a larger job so polishing is
a fork of ethereum it's a full system
state fork that means the whole sys the
whole ethereum blockchain is getting
copied over so every ethereum user on
ethereum will get a copy of their coins
so as you see on my metamask
if that's what you should be there
any ethereum uh coins that you hold in
your metamask or your wallet like
anything uh if you hold it in the
private key in your private wallet not
on your coinbase or your whatever else
but you gotta hold it in your wallet
personal wallet
you'll get a copy everyone every theorem
user will get a copy of uh of their
copies everybody's gonna get a copy of
their ethereum assets on pulse shane so
let's say i have 53 000x right here and
that whenever the pulsing it comes out
everybody's going to get 53k hex or if
you have like chain link whatever tokens
you have on uh your ethereum wallet
you'll have them on your pulse chain
do you ever hear that saying um
i think we did it on a
unplugged alpha show in the last couple
weeks oh comes razor you know the
concept of
you know
i think it was winston churchill it said
if you can't comp you know explain
something simply no it wasn't churchill
it was einstein if you can't explain
something simply then you don't
understand it right like
uh [ __ ] baffles brains
right let's just completely brush over
the fact that the guy that set up this
token has a bit of a peppered past and
somebody owns eighty-eight percent of
the tokens that are minted
on your polishing network so if you if
you hold shiba in you if you hold chain
link or any other ethereum asset and
you're [ __ ] in your own private
wallet you'll have them copied over to
paul shane now what is this going to do
this is going to bring people over
because it's basically free money
there's there's gonna be value like oh
but you're printing currency out of thin
air oh you're just copying the free
coins so that's not happening no
okay free money
money money has never been free
the only look you know when i was a kid
uh
canadian tire is a retail store here you
know the canadian folks here watching
the show will understand just think of
like lowe's home depot something like
that like a hardware store
sells everything tires batteries cars
[ __ ] whatever appliances
they used to give out this paper money
it was like free money so you'd spend
like i don't know a dollar and they
would give you like paper money that
said five cents on it or something like
that
and the vast majority of that was never
used it was thrown in the garbage um
you know there were people selling it
online for like 10 cents on a dollar you
know so the people that were eager to
get their hands on it they would uh they
would use it and buy stuff but anything
that's free generally doesn't have any
value okay so another good indication of
a scam is oh you'll just freely make
free [ __ ] just you know do this
sacrifice or whatever the hell it is and
you'll make free [ __ ]
anybody i made a video about it you can
watch another description here but
they're going to have value there's
going to be free money for everyone to
come into polish and use it and
basically they'll be incentivized the
whole ethereum user base which has 185
million this is what happens guys when
you go like way too far with playing to
win
like this kid is so ego invested in
like there's 19 500 tokens completely
ignores the top ten completely ignores
number one says it's a [ __ ] coin
goes all the way down to
where are we with hex what what is this
on the uh the list of tokens
uh rank 201 goes all the way down to 201
on the list and says this is the one
that i want
right because this will be an easy fast
way to turn 12 500 into 62 million
dollars
right i mean
that's what happens when you go too hard
man and you don't stop to reflect
you just like you just can't put
yourself in a position of exposure like
this i mean look
kid 17 it's 12 500
maybe he gets out you know what enough
maybe he maybe he doesn't but it's gonna
be a twelve thousand five hundred dollar
university tuition
i've lost money before on dumb [ __ ] you
know been scammed by all kinds of stuff
been scammed by people been scammed by
corporations been scammed by
uh investing advice many many times in
my life so trust me i know how to spot
[ __ ] like this uh wallets individual
addresses well i just don't mean like
people but because people have multiple
addresses but basically the world's
largest air drop is going to basically
incentivize 185 million addresses to
come over and test out polishing to get
the free copies
so we have the tokenomics we have the
buying burn on politics and we have the
burn on pulse chain
so it's deflationary the supply goes
down it pumps so we have that we have
the world's largest air drop that's
going to bring 185 million addresses
ethereum addresses let's say 180 million
people over to paul shane because they
have free coins on fall chain so we'll
get adopted we'll get more users like
that over time as more people know about
you know oh i have free money let me go
to polish oh what is this what is
possible what is hex and they buy it
so that's the marketing and what else uh
well it has lower gas fees but you know
binance has lower gas fees uh [ __ ]
like phantom has lower gas piece but our
gas we are cheaper than them but it's
cheap so that's the other point because
and it's a full you can always spot a
cult member because they're like hour
like our stuff is cheaper right like
take take my pill
my pill is the one to take hour pill
right
this is the uh what color is hex purple
ish i don't know take the hex pill
system stay forward so basically
all the projects that are on ethereum
that can't work because the gaskets are
high they can work on polishing so more
people come in it's lower gas fees and
that's pretty much everything special
about uh pulse chain really like it has
better tokenomics than uh ethereum it's
actually more better because it's
actually decentralized i don't want to
get into like how uh ethereum 2.0
i hate to be a language nazi but
whenever i hear it's more better
i just get like whatever it could be
because he's a romanian kid and english
may not be his first language but
staking it's not a fixtures it's not to
do anything it's and it's going to be
more uh centralized because the e32
ethereum two-state it sucks polish is
way better it's basically just think of
caution as east 2.0 but on steroids way
better so i mean what else is there to
talk about told you about polishing
pulse x if you have any questions please
join the discord i talk on here every
single day 12 a.m eastern time i talk to
them you can ask me questions and i can
help you and you can watch my videos and
get to know more like i made a video
about it and again one of the hallmarks
of a cult is join my discord join my
whatever it's like i remember when i was
a kid and the jehovah's witnesses were
still walking around the neighborhoods
knocking on doors on you know the
weekends trying to sell you you know to
join their club
it's you know it's the same thing like
you know these are the benefits you know
come over here i'll answer your
questions for free i'm a good guy blah
blah blah blah
oh let me just go look
i mean it's somewhere around here
where's where is it what is paul shane
is 1000x what is
uh pulse x incoming 1000 action coming
what hex what is hex hex is a cd i don't
talk about hex like what it is i made a
video about it well i haven't actually
made a video about it but basically hex
did a 10 000 x if you bought from the
old time bottom yes if you bought from
the all time bottom in 1.6 years you
would have got a ten thousand x that
means if you put one dollar in you would
get a ten thousand dollars back
easily if you bought right here you
would get like a thousand x like i mean
two thousand x from if you just bought
here if you accumulated your [ __ ] here
if you got an early you would have got
2000 x uh if you got in here i think it
would be like 120x i'm not sure well we
can shoot them out
you would get a 506 560x if you bought
it here
so it did well this is but i don't want
to like get it make this video any
longer 350 minutes what what did i talk
about i talked about why paul 6 sounds
pretty impressive eh he's got the chart
to prove it we'll have a user base at
launch because people sacrifice for it
you can't respond by the way so don't
sacrifice you lose your money so
we're
we're gonna have a user base because
people stack us for it and you see the
numbers 141k people second fourth pulse
x so we have the user base we have the
economics the pump where we have the
binder on politics we have uh burn on
pulse chain
which means
supply goes down and for pulsex it burns
up and actually it burns up and buys up
the price so it pumps pulse x like the
pulsex system pumps itself up so we have
those two economics and third we have uh
the world's largest character that's
going to be the whole marketing stick
behind publishing like oh come get your
free money out of publishing you got to
use it ethereum users come over use paul
shane we'll get it like we'll get more
people like that and it has lower fees
which is always enticing
that's basically it i mean there's
really nothing else like i don't know
about like i don't know richard cooper's
portfolio not portfolio uh like how he
holds bitcoin and [ __ ] uh he likes takes
on celsius and he's a little bit of a
crypto newbie like i know more than him
but
like i know more than him
i don't know what his portfolio is
i don't know like if richard got a lot
of kids they're so innocent i don't know
how much what i was getting at is i
don't know richard cooper's like net
worth i don't know how much coins he
holds i don't know like what's his net
worth like how much is the person worth
how much is richard look unless you have
to publicly declare it like a guy like
warren buffett you shouldn't you should
never declare your net worth publicly
that's just a stupid move how's his
investment portfolio worth i don't know
how much that is
but if it's anything under 50 million
dollars 60 million 80 million dollars
uh in the next five years
in the next five years uh crazy numbers
like this is going to be crazy now it's
going to be worth millions and millions
of dollars if this would succeed but you
should
so virtual group doesn't take this
opportunity i'm probably gonna be worth
more than the guys so
i don't know what's going on here with
that chart but actually before i switch
over let me just play it to the end
because there's another minute wait
[ __ ] less money he can like mock the
shot if he puts his amount of money
which group has more money than me
[ __ ] a thousand times more money than
me i only have 12.5 my name which i
sacrificed all into politics and then
they go down another thing on uh paul
shane let's come out
what uh i don't know let's see
what uh this is gonna do very awesome it
doesn't show you the whole chart i'm
gonna show you the whole chart
successfully i'm gonna look back at this
video and hopefully richard cooper and
hopefully you guys will follow the
trooper are now aware this opportunity
so you're welcome but yeah there's
really nothing else to talk about so
thank you for watching richard is one of
my father figures this is the man that
read me and let me down the rabbit hole
okay all right that's enough
he's just trying to pay some homage
which is fine
and you know by the way guys i'm not
doing this as a hit video i'm just
i'm breaking something down okay this is
this is this is fair commentary on
something that's relevant to
what i deal with because i'm the chase
excellence guy i'm the do the work guy
put in the reps right
um so let's share
stop screen and let's pull up the hex
chart to see where they're at because he
didn't show you
he didn't give you a fair representation
of hex by showing you that chart
all right
let's see if we can make this a little
bigger for the screen
come on screen cooperate there you go
and boom
okay so this is so on coin mark you can
oh well it's gone up 106
coins since i looked at this last number
of cryptos this last time i looked was
19 500 and now there's 19 606.
so and in the last few days a bunch of
people made 106 new cryptocurrencies
that's that's how common this [ __ ] is
okay
so this is the full chart on hex
it started over here if you're one of
these people that got in over here good
for you good for you over here there's a
big buying bump another big buying bump
another big buying bump these are all
the early adopters okay
um
there's there's 88 percent of the tokens
held by
one individual purportedly
which means all of these big buying
bumps over here in the early phases
probably amount to another five percent
of all the tokens and they're probably
buddies of whoever you know created this
whole thing
some people call this a rug pull they
call it a pump and dump
and then here's a chart right so you're
basically saying oh you can make a 10
000 x yeah if you measure from here to
here
which was in september of 2021 if you're
one of these guys good for you
you know you probably turn twelve
thousand five hundred dollars into 62
million dollars if you were one of these
early adopters over here but look at the
trend of this chart since then since
2021
it's just gone in the toilet man
it's worth seven cents
everybody that i talked to that's been
all you know
up and uh you know up and up about hacks
to me
has been complaining to me the last uh
little while
the um the guy that was filming my um uh
heroes trip so the highlight reel that
you saw on my channel in the last couple
weeks
the one percent hero strip
he was just going on and on about it
right
i hate it stupid i can't believe i fell
for it
right so this is where some people are
now that bought up in the hype right
this is where most of the buying
happened like look at these buying uh
pyramids over here look at them all
there's one over here there's a big one
over here there's a big buying pyramid
over here
there's a couple over here you know this
time these are all people that like
bought into the idea that you buy this
stuff and you stake it for 38 or 40 and
sacrifice it and lock it up and all this
[ __ ] and i'll explain how it works in a
minute
but all these people like these guys
over here did okay if they got out these
these buyers over here because the price
is going up so i know these are buyers
you know these are not sellers okay all
these buyers over here these are all the
people that got [ __ ]
because look at the price of the token
now
so i don't i don't know what the lock-up
period is if it's a year or two or
whatever the hell it happens to be and
you know what you lose to unlock early
but there's clearly a locking period
based on the way that it's been
explained
anyway
so you don't get the whole chart from
this young fella
um so that's the end of it he just
basically goes on to say you know he
really likes my content i've changed his
life and all that sort of stuff but
you know like everybody takes
everybody interprets what i talk about
in their own way
and
like i feel somewhat responsible for
this kid
because he's watched so much of my [ __ ]
and he's like i owe my success to him
and his big idea of success is putting
his life savings which isn't a lot i
mean that's at 17 like who cares 12 500
he'll make that back in no time you know
if you lose it
but it'll but it'll it's gonna hurt
right like i know what it costs for me
when i was a teenager
when i was his age i had a suzuki katana
600 motorcycle i had my own car i was
paying for insurance on them i had my
own job and i was going to school and i
was hanging out with friends so
basically my entire world would have
would have collapsed all my savings all
my toys
you know would have just been like poof
see you later bye
so i don't know
um
got jimbo in the chat saying i think i
almost got a hex didn't end up going
into it thankfully
and this kid is literally telling
everyone they can easily get rich
without developing any skills or
producing nothing it's literally crazy
yeah like
i'm not the only one that sees that
again you know if you're one of these
guys down over here and these buying
bumps
right back up on the the screen
this buying bump this buying bump
this buying bump over here this big
buying pyramid over here if you're one
of these guys and you got out over here
good for you
you know congratulations
you timed it right
but all of these people during this time
over here that are seeing these videos
trying to trying to recruit noobs
because that's what the video really is
he's trying to recruit
noobs you know people that are in my
audience that
see my name in the title with my image
to go check out what he has to say
promising you know 5000 x 10 000 x so
i take offense to that right
like i said before there's you know
there's no shortcut to success there's
only work every everybody that you could
point to that you'd call an overnight
success i guarantee there's 10 20 maybe
even 30 years of work behind that
success that you only see today
right you don't see all the mistakes
along the way you don't see the the the
scars the cuts the sleepless nights you
know the lawyers you don't see any of
that [ __ ]
and a 17 year old kid who's only walked
this planet for 17 years 17 years is
going to dispense legitimate advice on
how to make money hey guys i really hope
that you enjoyed that short clip if you
did consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you